[Music]
i am the repository for dead people's
things i have items from my parents and
both sets of grandparents that hold such
sentimental value to me
but they also clutter my home i want to
let go but where's the best place to
start is it with my own stuff or someone
else's
okay
it's funny because we talked about this
on the minimal episode where do i start
with my stuff for someone else's and i
was like
who would you just start throwing i mean
it is it's much easier to throw away
other people's things for sure
but she's talking about other people's
sentimental items they're not but she's
also talking about how
they're dead people so they're not other
people's things they're your things yeah
right here's what i'll tell you you
don't want to start with the difficult
things because you don't have any
momentum right now and letting go
you want the little small victories up
front right and so i did it all wrong
when i first stumbled into simplifying
it wasn't my stuff it was when my mom
passed away
and i was confronted with an entire
house full of stuff we were just moving
last weekend and ella was like it took
the movers three whole hours
and i said ella when i dealt with just
my mom's stuff
it took me 12 whole days yeah and part
of that was be and she was well why'd it
take so long well because she had so
much stuff and ella all she knows is you
know the life she's actually why would
people have so much stuff
and
because having so much stuff having a
super abundance and over abundance is
excess excess is not a default state
excess is the place
in which we suffer
excess pain
excess cell growth causes cancer right
excess inflammation
these things are all
well they're harmful to us but excess
stuff causes a lot of pain in our lives
as well and so
it's about starting with the simple
things that's why we invented the 30-day
minimalism game it's like just get rid
of one thing on day one
and on second day two things
you just gotta start somewhere and i
wouldn't start with the sentimental
items you can eventually get to the
sentimental items but how do you let go
of them well there's a few things you
need to realize here pamela
these things are not other people's
things they are now your things amen it
is now your responsibility now
you don't have to get rid of any of them
you're at a point though where you have
too many of these things it's not that
they all create clutter it's too many
things create clutter and so yes you
have too many things from dead people
and holding on to all of them is going
to water down the sentimental value of
those things by keeping just a handful
of my mom's items i get far more value
from those things than if i were to
water them down with 300 000
excess items and so the question that i
asked myself is what's going to add
value to my life what's going to serve a
purpose or bring me joy maybe it's
decorative and so there's some sort of
aesthetic joy that you get from it or
maybe it's something i can actually use
and that thing still triggers the
memories everything else i took photos
of and eventually let go of them because
i realized that
i couldn't co-mingle mom's stuff with my
stuff it was just going to get in the
way i was just going to store it in a
mausoleum of stuff and so i decided to
let go of the things that were dead to
me so i could hold on to the things that
would serve a purpose now if they stop
serving a purpose i have no problem with
letting go of those things because the
meaning the value the sentimentality is
not in the thing ryan if i gave you my
mom's hat box
and said here hold on to this it has a
lot of sentimental value the only
appropriate response to that is
to you
it has a sentimental value to you but it
doesn't have inherent sentimental value
right and so there's a
what's the thomas soul quote podcast
sean
without trade-offs
oh they're um in life yes there are no
solutions only trade-offs right and what
we're talking about here is a trade-off
right because
yes they have sentimental value to you
but they also clutter your home and so
you're willing right now to trade
clutter the chaos
you're willing to accept some of the
chaos
because you get some sort of value from
them what i would posit is perhaps you
may get more value from having fewer
sentimental items and simultaneously
you'll be allowed giving yourself
permission to let go of the clutter yeah
i mean really what you're talking about
is that question we tell people to ask
all the time is how might your life be
better with less
and pamela yes it would be better
because you wouldn't have as much
clutter you would have a little space
freed up not just physically but also in
your mind um yeah and these
there's not an easy decision here
but getting to the why behind like
that's what's gonna help her
uh
the path will unfold as soon as she gets
clear on the why
the what will appear yes indeed and
that's important and if you're looking
for a how to once you understand the why
check out the 30-day minimalism game the
minimalists.com slash game you can
download the free calendar there and you
can make decluttering a bit more fun
because right now it's burdensome and as
soon as something is burdensome you
don't you just want to hide from it the
grief
the lamenting
the trauma that is associated with these
things
by working through it by letting go
you're also letting go of the trauma
you're going to feel more grief in the
meantime but suppressing that grief is
only going to lead to more trauma later
on so make it a little more fun partner
up with a friend a family member try the
30 day minimalism game the
minimalists.com game it's free to play
share your pictures of your letting go
using the men's game
m-i-n-s
game men's game
did you enjoy this stand-alone patreon
highlight if so you can listen to full
episodes of the minimalist private
podcast available exclusively on patreon
visit patreon.com
the minimalists or click the link in the
description your support keeps our
podcast and youtube channel 100
advertisement free